a significance test is going to be
performed using a significance level of
five hundredths suppose that the null
hypothesis is actually false
if the significance level was lowered to
100 which of the following would be true
so pause this video and see if you can
answer it on your own
okay now let's do this together and
let's see they're talking about how the
probability of a type 2 error or the
power or and or the power would change
so before i even look at the choices
let's think about this we've talked
about in previous videos that if we
increase our level of significance that
will increase our power
and power is the probability of not
making a type 2 error so that would
decrease the probability of making a
type
error
but in this question we're going the
other way we're decreasing the level of
significance which would lower the
probability of making a type 1 error but
this would decrease the power
it actually would increase it actually
would increase the probability of making
a type
a type 2 error and so which of these
choices are consistent with that
well choice a says that both the type
two error and the power would decrease
well those don't these two things don't
move together if one increases the other
decreases so we rule that one out choice
b also has these two things moving
together which can't be true if one
increases the other decreases
choice c the probability of a type ii
error would increase that's consistent
with what we have here and the power of
the test would decrease yep that's
consistent with what we have here so
that looks good and choice d is the
opposite of that the probability of a
type 2 error would decrease
so this is they're talking about this
scenario over here and that would have
happened if they increased our
significance level not decreased it so
we could rule that one out as well let's
do another example
asha owns a car wash and is trying to
decide whether or not to purchase a
vending machine so that customers can
buy coffee while they wait she'll get
the machine if she's convinced that more
than 30 percent of our customers would
buy coffee she plans on taking a random
sample of n customers and asking them
whether or not they would buy coffee
from the machine and she'll then do a
significance test using alpha equals
0.05 to see if the sample proportion who
say yes is significantly greater than 30
percent
which situation below would result in
the highest power for her test so again
pause this video and try to answer it
well before i even look at the choices
we can think about what her hypotheses
would be her null hypothesis is you
could kind of view it as a status quo no
no news here and that would be that the
true population proportion of people who
want to buy coffee is 30 percent and
that her alternative hypothesis is that
no the true population proportion the
true population parameter there is
greater than
is greater than 30 percent
and so if we're talking about what would
result in the highest power for her test
so
a high power
a high power means the the lowest
probability of making a type 2 error and
in other videos we've talked about it
looks like she's dealing with the sample
size and what is the true proportion of
customers that would buy coffee and the
sample size is under her control the
true proportion isn't don't want to make
it some seem like somehow you can change
the true proportion in order to get a
higher power you can change the sample
size
but the general principle is the higher
the sample size the higher the power so
you want a highest possible sample size
and you're going to have a higher power
if the true proportion is further from
your hypothesis your null hypothesis
proportion
and so we want the highest possible n
and that looks like an n of 200 which is
there and there and we want a true
proportion of customers that would
actually buy coffee as far away as
possible from our
null hypothesis which once again would
not be under asha's control but you can
clearly see that 50
is further from 30 than 32 is so this
one choice d is the one that looks good